los brasileños residentes en España ya
han ejercido su derecho y obligación a
voto en esta primera vuelta de las
presidenciales de Brasil a las 5 de la
tarde hora española cerraban los dos
colegios habilitados para ello en Madrid
y Barcelona en esta casa de Brasil de la
capital española el clima verano llegó a
favorecido una constante presencia de
votantes que expresaban sus ganas de
menos corrupción y de mejoras en su país
con opiniones que abarcaban todas las
ideologías de los 30.000 brasileños
censados para votar en España y aunque
todos los observadores aseguraban que la
participación ha sido mucho mayor que en
años anteriores aún no hay cifras
oficiales de asistencia y en cuanto a
los resultados A falta de confirmación
por parte de Brasilia Lula da Silva
llevaba una gran ventaja de votos frente
a Yair bolsonaro por lo menos aquí en
Madrid durante la segunda vuelta de 2018
en Madrid un 54% de los votantes se
decantó por Jay bolsonaro mientras que
en Barcelona fue el entonces candidato
del partido de los trabajadores fernando
adad el que Ob una mayoría de apoyos con
el 47% del voto habrá que esperar al
conteo final para saber cómo influyen
los resultados finales de estas
elecciones el voto en el exterior y si
la vuelta de Lula da Silva a la
contienda ha tenido algo que ver con
esto